this is a D1 a die that will always and
only roll one number
one is it a joke no it is a candle on a
cake that we baked to celebrate geometry
our daenery dice set a set of ten dice
in which each next die allows you to
decide between one more option than the
die before the D1 is not weighted in the
bottom it works because its shape is
monostatic there's only one way it can
stably balance we spent two years making
sure each die was as Fair as possible
that's why I'm so excited that they're
here they will be in the next next
curiosity box we're only gonna make so
many so the best way to ensure we make a
set for you is to join right now if you
do your first box will come with the
hurricane balls a portable sound
visualizer redesigned and more
how about this you can save twenty
dollars off your first box by joining
right now with code
one
[Music]